cette phrase qu'on vous attribue que
vous n'avez jamais prononcé c'est
vraiment la pire légende urbaine de tous
les temps et Dieu dans tout ça mais
c'est bien quand même de rester dans la
légende de la radio pour une phrase
qu'on a jamais prononcé
notre invité principale ce soir c'est
Jacques Chancel
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir Thierry alors j'arrive
vous êtes ici ce soir parce que vous
avez marqué le petit écran vous êtes
l'un des derniers grands de la
télévision française il reste qui vous
Bellemare il y en a beaucoup de la
première Gilbert
vous a inventé beaucoup de choses à la
télévision Jacques c'est vrai que le
coup de l'animateur qui se tape
l'assistante de plateau dans sa loge
c'est vous non parce que j'étais
peut-être un peu trop peureux j'ai
jamais osé alors Jacques Ampère nous
serons tous les deux nous parlerons de
vous de vos origines de votre jeunesse
de votre parcours de vos émissions et du
livre que vous publiez chez Flammarion
n'oublie pas de vivre c'est une phrase
de votre père mais comme ça se passait
dans les Hautes-Pyrénées vous a pas dit
n'oublie pas de vivre [ __ ] de Kong non
il ne parlait pas comme ça et d'autre
part il parlait également la langue du
pays que j'ai parlé moi jusqu'à l'âge de
10 ans et je la chante encore
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes journaliste écrivain de
radio et de télévision vous êtes
conseiller de Bertrand Méheut le
président de Canal+ ça va vous êtes bien
installé là ça va très bien
alors vous êtes né le 2 juillet 1928 à
Isaac host près d'Argelès Gazost dans
les Hautes-Pyrénées en Bigorre sous le
nom de Joseph crampe voilà vous êtes
fils unique d'Auguste crampe compagnon
du devoir escalieriste et de
Marie-Thérèse Bourdette votre père était
rescapé de la Grande Boucherie de 14-18
alors vous dites dans le livre que votre
père vous disait l'homme peut vite
devenir barbare mais il m'avait dit
surtout ce qui m'avait beaucoup frappé
parce que mon 18 a été une victoire il
m'avait dit toute victoire est une
défaite des hommes ah c'est bien et cela
m'avait beaucoup frappé voilà
alors vous êtes pensionnaire au collège
Saint-Pée de Bigorre vous lisez
Alexandre Dumas Jack London et vous vous
rêvez en aventurier et vous y
parviendrez à 17 ans après l'école des
transmissions de Montargis vous montez
sur votre âge pour partir en Indochine
en fait vous avez 79 ans et pas 82
Jacques monsieur cotrinet qui était mon
instituteur a eu vraiment la gentillesse
de me vieillir autrement je l'aurais
jamais pu partir et lorsque j'avais
35-40 ans je lui ai dit par pur
honnêteté il faut très maintenant
peut-être qu'on rétablise la vérité il
m'a répondu lorsqu'on a triché une fois
on ne triche pas une seconde chance
et alors vous dites à cet âge là ça ne
compte plus j'ai été vieux trop tôt et
je suis jeune trop tard mais je suis
d'une jeunesse inconsciente alors vous
êtes attiré par l'ailleurs indochinois
vous aviez un oncle et une tente là-bas
lui était inspecteur des forêts elle
était proviseur de lycée et vous
raconter dans dans le livre qui nous
occupe que vous quittez 7 pour rejoindre
Saigon sur un vieux raphyo qui s'appelle
le santé
52 jours de
traverseri oui non mais c'était
totalement dément quoi et puis en plus
un vieux ratio c'était pas un bateau de
croisière et dans le même temps nous
avions une petite orchestre qu'on avait
formé moi j'étais allé à contrebasse
c'était assez facile quoi je ne sais pas
si je jouais faut juste mais je jouais
alors quand vous arrivez à Saïgon comme
vous travaillez à la radio radio
française les services de sécurité vous
demandent de changer de nom et là vous
prenez Jacques Chancel c'est pas en
hommage à Sheila
mais je crois qu'elle n'était pas encore
né oui c'est possible non
alors à Saïgon vous logez au fameux
Hôtel Continental vos voisins de chambre
s'appellent Lucien Bodart Jean lartegi
Graham green pierre schendorfers
par jour sur radio française et puis
vous êtes correspondant de guerre pour
Paris Match vous travaillez pour la RTF
ancêtre de l'ORTF vous allez passer huit
ans en Asie huit ans entre l'Indochine
la Chine le Japon donc d'une certaine
manière je suis un tout petit peu Asia
quoi quand vous parlez de cette époque
vous dites mes années d'apprentissage
fulgurante et douloureuses bah oui ça a
été à la fois très beau parce que on
avait de très belles émissions et puis
il y a eu la cruauté de la guerre
d'abord beaucoup de mes copains qui sont
morts lorsque par exemple on parle de la
baie d'hallow qui est l'une des plus
belles merveilles du monde pour moi la
baie d'avance c'est un cimetière 10 de
mes copains hein 131 et ils avaient
entre 20 et 22 ans mon père m'a dit
lorsque je suis rentré j'ai eu des
douleurs comme les tiennes peut-être
même peut-être plus on sait jamais mais
maintenant je te donne simplement comme
référence à seulement une seule phrase à
partir de cette seconde n'oublie pas de
vivre et je veux dire que je l'ai écouté
et que je l'écoute encore quand vous
êtes là-bas un moment vous êtes blessé à
la tête et vous perdez la vue ça s'est
passé comment cette histoire nous avons
sauté sur une mine on était sorti pour
aller voir un idiote que le capitaine
avait décelé dans le coin c'était du
côté de canoë là nous avons sauté et le
capitaine lui a été amputé des deux bras
et des deux jambes c'était séance là que
je dis que c'était une époque cruelle
voilà alors ensuite c'est le retour en
France vous travaillez une dizaine
d'années dans la dans la presse écrite
et en septembre 1968 vous créez
l'émission qui vous rendra célèbre
radioscopie une heure de conversation en
direct sans interruption musicale
vous avez ni publicité ni musiques
ou à la radio on faisait autre chose que
demander aux auditeurs d'appeler pour
dire n'importe quoi mais ça c'est autre
chose c'est ce qu'on appelle comment
aujourd'hui c'est un mot
non non non non interactivité moi je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse véritablement
qu'un journaliste digne de ce nom puisse
démissionner devant ceux qui l'écoutent
et ceux qui l'écoutent souvent moi je
les vois je les entends ils m'ont pas
ils me disent mais on parle façon de
nous demander nous on lorsque l'écoute
la radio qu'on regarde la télévision on
a envie d'apprendre alors il y aura 6826
entretiens radioscopie il y avait il y
avait tout le monde il y avait même moi
j'ai publié mon premier livre m'avait
reçu d'envoyer parce que je me demandais
d'ailleurs si vous étiez encore
monarchiste c'était écouté c'était
formidable je vous remercie aujourd'hui
vous êtes le premier à m'avoir
interviewé voilà
voilà ensuite vous entrez dans
l'histoire de la télé avec le Grand
Échiquier en direct trois heures minimum
5h15 avec la Comédie française c'est
absolument extraordinaire il y avait 120
musiciens 200 choristes tout à fait
particulier parce que le matin j'avais
enterré mon père dans les Pyrénées
un avion mais ce qui était beau lorsque
je suis rentré dans ma loge il y avait
mais ça de paquets de témoignages des
gens de la Comédie Française qui tousse
me racontait ce qu'ils avaient vécu j'ai
perdu ma femme j'ai perdu mon mari j'ai
perdu un enfant mais c'était prodigieux
et comme on dit le spectacle continue
provoquer des rencontres extraordinaires
yudi menuisine qui joue avec Ravi
Shankar avec les violoneux
écossais avec les Tziganes de Hongrie
j'ai fait jouer avec avec tout le monde
et alors caisse nationale qui accompagne
Serge Lama dans les petites femmes de
Pigalle c'est incroyable avec Laurine
Mazel qui en plus quitte la direction de
l'orchestre il prend le violon pour la
compter la compagnie tout à côté Michel
Serrault qui se fait une omelette sur un
réchaud sous un piano là il m'a mis dans
le dans le pétrole bah oui parce que je
vois le chef d'aciturité qui me dit
arrêtons les conneries parce que regarde
je dis je regarde de quoi moi je ne
l'avais pas vu il y avait un grand piano
à queue il était sous le piano il y
avait un rachelot à gaz il se faisait
des œufs
il y avait les règles de sécurité
dentaire voilà le grand classique
on en est loin voilà alors tout ça
toujours avec la volonté d'imposer la
culture au plus grand nombre votre
fameuse phrase je dirais un petit peu
votre votre devise on ne doit pas donner
au téléspectateurs ce qu'ils aiment mais
ce qu'ils pourraient aimer c'est la
seule manière de faire un cadeau vous
êtes pas tendre avec la télévision
d'aujourd'hui vous dites dans le livre
qui nous occupe on ne cesse d'inventer
des éphémères et de remplir les soirées
avec des rigolos le drame aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a énormément énormément de
chaînes ce qui est également un bonheur
donc on peut choisir et choisir cette
éliminer lorsque j'entends les gens dire
mais c'est minable j'ai mes chers ne
restez pas toujours avec les mêmes
émissions et d'autre part lorsqu'on
parle de la télé-réalité ou toutes ces
émissions je dois dire c'est le
téléspectateur qui n'est pas innocent la
plupart du temps les gens demandent des
émissions alors qu'ils sa pertinemment
qu'ils ne les regarderont jamais alors
ils disent pourquoi pas une grande
émission sur la musique à 20h30 pour que
une grande émission sur la littérature à
20h30 et après ils ne vont pas au
rendez-vous
alors vous en prenez également au
producteur qui pioche dans les archives
de Lina ce que j'appelle les voleurs ils
font pas la télévision vous dites ils
font du fric ils font du fric attention
qu'on se sert des images de Lina si vous
m'invitez comme vous le faites et si
tout d'un coup vous me montrez un
extrait du fantasy ça c'est normal on
est dans le bain mais ce qui prennent
toutes les archives qui ensuite signent
une émission 2 ça c'est beaucoup plus
riche que nous c'est leur problème sinon
pas de dignité c'est pas de leur faute
alors en 2007 vous qui nous étiez jamais
engagés politiquement vous avez déclaré
Nicolas Sarkozy et l'homme qu'il faut à
la France Sarkozy est un vieil ami un
vieil ami leur restera toujours et moi
je suis de ceux qui l'ont accompagné
dans ce que l'appelait à un certain
moment elle traversait du désert
aujourd'hui il est président de la
République et je n'ai jamais été un
cortisan il reste l'ami mais il est le
président alors est-ce que Sarkozy est
l'homme qu'il fallait la télévision
parce que ça change
vos émissions mais qu'est-ce que ça a
changé sur le service public la
suppression de la publicité
il est vrai que que ça puisse vraiment
arranger beaucoup de gens après 20
heures d'avoir des programmes qui
commencent à une certaine heure et qui
ne sont pas entrecoupés il y a des
tunnels de publicité quand même surtout
tes chaînes maintenant il y a des
formats courts
alors vous citez la phrase de Alex
Ferguson l'entraîneur de Manchester je
suis trop vieux pour prendre ma retraite
je laisse ça aux jeunes mais c'est vrai
mais regardez vous les avez pas vu
récemment avec des banderoles à nous la
retraite donc vous imaginez ils sont
très jeunes
et puis bon ben pour terminer cette
phrase qu'on vous attribue que vous
n'avez jamais prononcé c'est vraiment la
pire légende urbaine de tous les temps
et Dieu dans tout ça mais c'est bien
comme de rester dans la légende de la
radio pour une phrase qu'on a jamais
prononcé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu